pour faire votre marché et même en
extérieur il faudra vous munir désormais
d'un masque de protection
une obligation depuis le 15 août 8
heures fixées par arrêté de la
préfecture des yvelines et qui concerne
également les vide greniers et brocante
du département ces derniers jours les
indicateurs sanitaires montrent une
forte dégradation de la situation avec
une reprise importante de la circulation
du coc u19 en l'absence d'une réaction
collective rapide le pays s'expose à une
reprise épidémique difficile à contrôler
il est donc aujourd'hui plus que
nécessaire d'étendre encore davantage le
port du masque ce mardi matin sur le
marché notre dame de versailles les
personnes sans masques étaient plutôt
rares elle a mesuré bien accepté même si
certains demandent davantage de
communication autour de cet arrêté
préfectoral
j'ai pas eu d'infos précises même à
l'état il en préside donc je me suis dit
que c'était pas obligatoire
ça me paraît logique ça me paraît même
très bien tous les gens on sait jamais
ce qu'ils on comprends moi je comprends
tout à fait ce qui se passe en ce moment
et j'ai même peur pour moi c'est
vraiment limiter les risques donc autant
le faire
je pense qu'il n'y a pas d'autre et
voilà y'a pas d'autre solution l'heure
actuelle on peut par confiner donc le
mieux c'est vraiment de porter le masque
pour tout le monde et d'éviter de se
contaminer entre nous du côté de ce
commerçant la disposition rassurer et
jugé nécessaire pour éviter une deuxième
vague et un nouveau confinement si
l'habitude on leur fait comprendre que
appartient au mans il ya du monde il
faut le mettre si tout simplement
logique
je pense que les mesures les plus
extrêmes elles ont déjà été prises en
faisant le confinement
on pourra plus trop se permettre je
pense déjà économiquement
rien que le fait de mettre ce masque si
ça peut endiguer la deuxième vague tout
le monde tout le monde le fera tout le
monde le fera sans aucun problème je
pense bien et je l'espère chaque
contrevenant s'expose à 135 euros
damende le week-end du 15 août près de
200 contrôles ont été effectués par les
forces de l'ordre yvelinoise ils vont
aller crescendo dans le département les
communes du vésinet de carrières sous
poissy ont également pris des arrêtés
pour rendre le masque obligatoire dans
les lieux les plus fréquentés